surprise I wanted to review this movie
on Halloween every single year I tell
myself I'm gonna review Halloween this
year this is your interview Halloween
and something gets in the way and this
was the year after our fourth annual
Halloween special my wife and I did I
wanted to talk about Halloween let's get
started
this movie came out in 1978 and was made
for the mere budget of $300,000 which
even then was extremely low and it
grossed 47 million dollars in just the
United States alone it's one of the most
profitable movies of all time it's
become culturally significant this movie
was impactful for that generation and
has since been passed on to other
generations and has become timeless so
with this review I didn't want to just
talk about the fact that Halloween's a
scary movie with Michael Myers and it
has a cool sound track and there's
knives and people scream and stuff which
I'll talk about but I wanted to focus on
why this movie has remained timeless
what is so special about Halloween a
movie about a guy who's crazy who's
stalking people why is this particular
film impacted so many people so as you
probably know Halloween is about Michael
Myers a young boy who in the very
effective and chilling opening scene
murders his sister Michael then we
flash-forward to 1978 and Jamie Lee
Curtis is the young girl who goes to
school who's not as promiscuous as her
friends she doesn't like to smoke
cigarettes she thinks they taste gross
her friends however who enjoy having sex
all the time and don't seem to have a
care in the world these characters
create the body count where Jamie Lee
Curtis the young naive virgin is the one
who's able to outsmart Michael Myers and
this started a long series of tropes in
horror movies where the people who were
having sex with the people who got
knocked off first and it's here in the
present day of 1978 that an adult
Michael Myers escapes an insane asylum
and his doctor Sam Loomis portrayed by
Donald Pleasance is trying to hunt him
down to figure out where he is before he
can kill too many people this movie was
directed by John Carpenter who had
previously directed assault on precinct
13 which by the way if you've never seen
it is a very fun
budget action movie and here his
Direction shines above anything else in
this film he took what is an incredibly
simple premise and with beautiful shot
composition used the foreground and the
background and things out of focus
things that are blurry suggestions hints
of things and a surprising lack of
violence to take this film in a far
better direction than perhaps it was on
paper because the dialogue in this film
isn't anything to write home about and
of course the iconic music composed and
performed by carpenter himself despite
the fact that he stated he can't write a
note it's kind of amazing how this film
has become a classic because so much of
it was sort of left to chance so much of
it kind of seemed up in the air the
masks they bought for Michael Myers was
for like a dollar or something
a William Shatner mask that they
spray-painted white and cut out the eyes
and that sense has become burned into
the minds of many children's and adults
nightmares but what is it exactly about
Halloween that has made it so culturally
impactful that has made it so timeless
for me personally I feel that beyond the
nostalgia beyond the fact that it's
connected to a holiday I feel that
because at its core this film examines
evil and how evil can infect somebody
and how someone can then allow that evil
to just take over their life and that
fascinating aspect of the character of
Michael Myers and what drives him to do
what he does along with the fact that
it's a very well-made movie is what I
think keeps audiences coming back
because evil and the examination of how
humanity and evil are connected is a
timeless subject and I think that's one
of the reasons that Halloween has
remained a film that people watch year
to year and not just because of the fact
that it's a great movie nevertheless it
captures the fun of a Halloween night
you carve pumpkins you watch scary
movies you have fun with your friends
and then shit turns really bad but you
know it really feels like oh this is so
cozy and warm I love this movie and you
just want to bundle up in a blanket and
watch Halloween on Halloween it-it's so
much fun to do that every year but
something I wanted to do in this video
is something that I think people try to
stray away from doing whenever they
review
a classic film and that is talk about
some shitty aspects of it Halloween is
not a perfect movie uh-huh it's got
really terrible acting I mean the acting
sometimes who having fun nevermind I'm
sure you are easily the best actor in
this movie is Donald Pleasance his
performance is really good his speech
about evil how we saw it in Michael
Myers eyes one of the best scenes in the
movie I spent eight years trying to
reach him and then another seven trying
to keep him locked up because I realized
that what was living behind that boy's
eyes was pelion simply evil and Jamie
Lee Curtis is mostly fine she gets a
little over-the-top and a little whiny
and the screaming scenes later in fact
apparently Jamie Lee Curtis was
horrified by her performance in this
movie until John Carpenter told her she
did a good job but it's her friends in
particular the character of Annie mmm
Lindsay I hate this dog there's also
some very poor sound design at times
when Annie is being strangled they
reused the exact same sound effect a few
times this movie was plagued by some of
those technical issues because of the
budget it's something that you can
overlook all these years later because
the film as I said has been culturally
impactful and significant in that way
and it's just a really well directed
movie and extremely fun and it's a
Halloween tradition in regards to
negatives that's it John Carpenter
directed the shit out of this movie it
is so good-looking the score is awesome
it has remained timeless for a reason
because of its examination of evil I
feel and also because it's just a really
fun horror film and it started a shun
rrah a long list of imitators of
Halloween I'm going to give Halloween
and a
guys thank you so much as always for
watching this review I wanted to talk
about Halloween on my channel for a long
time I hope you guys checked out our
fourth annual Halloween special this
year my wife and I worked really hard on
that we're really proud of that and I
hope you check that out there's going to
be a link for that in just a second here
guys please do check that out we had a
ton of fun making it talking about a lot
of really cool horror films and doing a
short film interwoven throughout those
reviews guys thank you so much once
again as always and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]
you